Pete: So, what are the basic things that most
mobile OS's do in terms of helping enforce
security?
Like, what in these features in these, perhaps
somewhat immature, OS's that you mention that
developers can take advantage of?
Mike: Sure.
So, I'll cover two at a very high level.
We'll talk about application sandboxing first
of all.
And, that basically means your application
is running on the device and it's in its own
protected sandbox.
It can potentially write to the file system,
it can write and read to its own files, but
it can't necessarily touch the files of another
application.
So, if your banking application is storing
some sort of potentially sensitive data on
a file, the newest game that you've downloaded
can't necessarily, out of the box, reach in
and touch- you know, read- those bits of data.
The operating system won't let that happen.
Now, when the device is jailbroken, those
controls are removed.
And now, a rogue or malicious application
running on the device is running at a higher
privilege level and can potentially do a lot
of things.
It can attack other applications, it can abuse
other bits of functionality on the phone,
like turn on the microphone, for example,
steal your contacts or send out SMS messages
or email.
The other bit that I'd like to talk about,
would be security data storage.
So, I've already talked a little bit about
just data storage on the device- writing to
files.
You don't want to- if you're, for example,
storing credentials on the device, or you
have the need to store credentials on a device
so that a user doesn't need to enter them
every time, they authenticate to your app.
You don't want to just write them to a flat
text file in plaintext on the device.
Something like that is easily recoverable,
whether or not the device is jailbroken.
And, we're talking about applications using
it.
If the person loses their device, you don't
want somebody to be able to pick it up and,
with minimal skill or ability, be able to
pull a file off your device and now have your
banking credentials.
So, the platforms provide certain methods
of securely storing data on the devices.
For example, on iOS, there's the keychain.
Data stored in the keychain isn't necessarily
encrypted unless the user has a passcode on
their device.
So, if they don't have a passcode on their
device, and as a developer, you're storing
something in the keychain, and the device
is not jailbroken, you have the application
sandboxing.
So, my app can't access your app's credentials.
But, if an attacker picks up the device and
has physical access to it, he can get at that
keychain data and it's not protected without
the passcode.
So, there are lots of little nuances that
people need to be aware of.
Pete: Do you think developers are commonly
aware that this sort of scenario exists?
For instance, on the iOS platform?
Mike: I think the documentation could always
be improved upon.
And there's a lot of just general awareness
that needs to happen.
It's also very easy to go down the encryption
rabbit hole, 'OK, we know we need to protect
this data, so let's encrypt it and we'll use
a symmetric key.'
You come across that quite often when you're
reviewing mobile applications.
You just happen to find a hardcoded encryption
code right in the application code base, used
to store the credentials and the file system
"encrypted".
But, what the developers don't always realize
is that that key is easily recoverable, and
now, in that case, OK, now the key is on a
million devices for the one million users
that have installed your application.
So, now you've got a situation where a bad
buy can say, 'OK, well, I see how poorly this
app is protecting this sensitive data, I can
see, based on the number of downloads, that
it's installed on bizillions of devices, now
I can target this application.
And, I can write a trojan or some piece of
malware that will masquerade as a legitimate
mobile application and seek out this other
app on the installed user base.'